Montezuma ran a vibrant Empire from one
of the world's largest cities with an
amazing headdress but unlike his Mayan
neighbors he didn't leave us books and
monuments full of sentences and yet we
know the Aztecs called him wait Lonnie
not Emperor that he didn't call
chocolate chocolate and that Montezuma
is not how he said his name no no that's
not it either
after college I went through linguistics
withdrawal so I tore through any
language e-book I could including
empires of the word right away there's
this epic encounter between Spanish
conquistadors and the Aztec emperor but
if we see a people inevitably about to
be wiped from history this book saw two
high cultures meeting across a great
divide each telling their own story in
their own words I lowered the book their
own words we know how Montezuma spoke
turns out we do partly because while
some brought swords to the new world
others reached for pens and informants
they wrote histories and dictionaries
and rough grammars with helpful tips
about Aztec well the Mexican language
Nahuatl tips like when you see two
consonants in a row pronounced both a
house was golly not guy you like if this
were Spanish tips like there are only
four vowels uh-oh so if you spot an ooh
it's really just in oh in disguise the
word for flower is show cheek vowels can
be long - ah a e o a flower isn't just
show cheek it's show cheek spelling is
clunky but it works if we see it as
Spanish letters layered over simple
Aztec sets sass AC soca keiki gota say C
so linguists would have done a better
job but bygones
above all the old grammar show off the
structure of not nouns attached affixes
hope do they ever nante non simply tone
on tone and sing Tito Nancy Donen seen a
verbs use incorporation jamming things
we'd call different words into a single
Peabody niqua me taqwa me Thomas quoi
the grammar only gets more fun from
there but there's a lot these pre-modern
grammars don't tell us take a concrete
example an important one chocolate
we suspect it must have come from
chocolate bitter water but there's no
trace of that in the early literature in
classical times the base word for the
bean and the drink was cacahuate to sort
out all these missing words and sounds
let's look into Montezuma's future and
his past
Montezuma's Aztecs also had books uh
mostly I was always told I'll mostly
were full of pictographs not real
writing but experts are taking a second
look spell the word see what woman as
you like here's how one glyph does with
two bars the bars stand for the syllable
hua compare that to the way colonial
writers spelled the sound war alwah cut
way II will see Wow
so this isn't a vowel ooh it's an H plus
u representing the consonant whoa but
our best evidence comes from modern
mouths
yep people still speak now what they may
call it Massa Wally meaning commoner or
even just Mexican but they help pin down
it sounds those UHS do indeed correspond
to was there really are just four vowels
and this fourth Belle dress freely
between o and O which explains those
earlier spelling variations and elephant
in the room or Jaguar in the temple but
this TL all over the place is kah you'll
even hear two K sounds as in skull golly
plus a tricky made by rounding your lips
la quiaca
this sound can even end a syllable de
the spelling here is awkward and
inconsistent today I'm going with this
one tie all this pronunciation analysis
together and we can dig up a glimpse of
what Montezuma's name sounded like in
his day motox ama motocross but out of
respect you might want to add the polite
suffix mode EXO matsing
did you hear that seem not seen certain
consonants were voiceless at the end of
a syllable try this one no cacao Wow
with a voiced woo in the middle and a
voiceless at the end ELLs are
particularly noticeable they're not I'll
their bed but I their bed but there were
still too many unknowns remember your
favorite sound well some speakers digit
they say nah what or now--all who's
right or take this H before consonant
colonial texts imprecisely called it a
Sal video a skip
come on the IPA wasn't even invented yet
today most people say me sheikah a few
same ashika which ones older zoom out
from now to see its siblings cousins
parents grandparents carefully comparing
them for patterns linguists proved
they're part of a Udo Aztec and family
that stretches from Central America up
to the western US linguists including
this guy Worf placed not within that
history Worf worked out that an early T
sound changed into oh so now what is
older wait later linguists showed this
change applied to the entire na one
branch now what and Noah were the
innovations so keep practicing your that
pesky sajda yo that sound you lop off
words when you borrow them even if it's
the Aztec name for themselves that was
even more elusive but hard work showed a
syllable final stop like a K or a T
turning into a catch in your throat
before becoming the popular sound in the
old days they said mushy got flat only
plot on E
oh and they stressed the second to last
syllable
we got waitlet awanee
so aztec had a family it also had
neighbors unrelated Mesoamerican
neighbors that all shared the same
features including a special ritual
language Aztec ritual speech was unlike
the common masa Wylie speech elite
schools cosmic hawk
totte noble children the old ways in
we're wet flat totally have you been
paying attention you know that show
cheat means flower and qui cut means
song well you still need ancient
parallelisms to grasp the noble phrase
in no shochu
in no Quico a stylish way to say my poem
this is the same ritual language from my
tale of the fall of the empire in mad
scene in more Tibet scene just to say
your City he was at the crossroads of an
ancient language one that wasn't just
about articulating not what the sounds
are building intricate words but making
your speech ringed with poetry like a
real Emperor I mean wait lotta wanna
stick around and subscribe for language
[Music]
you